おくらいや毎日 車で30分ぐらいもうもうん
高いでいっ うわーすっすっしたのでちょっとパンがね俺のいったでいい加減をすごい
5全部しとんじゃなかったものよっ
ていたら 私さん開いている方からからカラーでなぜようん
ん
なんで馬に乗り始めたのなんですか なんか
なんで馬の乗り始めたきっかけって何かあるん もうあの父が馬口がいだったからやっぱり
はぁはっきりだった 父様はの馬が大好きだよ あそうなんだよやっぱり子供の頃から乗っててねーかっ
ん
相当昔ですよね?明治?・・・いや・・・、そんなことないわ! 最初?父は明治よね? いや、やしこさんじゃないのよ。びっくりした・・・。
お父さんがその馬騎士街だった時代っていうのはさ・・・ 明治、明治ってことない?どうぞ。
でも、東大にいた頃、明治が最初になったのかもわからないけど・・・ 昔の方は、結構、軍隊でいっぱい馬持っていた。
今よりは、二次がだったんでしょうね。 学習院なんか、聖火で全員馬に乗らなきゃいけなかった。
でも、なんか、軍馬ですよね。 軍馬です。
やしこさんも入れちゃっていい? はい、お願いいたします。
じゃあ、軽井さんの街中で、馬に乗る時は・・・ スカートじゃ、乗れないですよね。
軽井さんでは、あんまり乗ったことないんです。 東京で毎週乗ってたので。
じゃあ、東京で乗る時は、そういう馬に乗る、ちゃんと格好で乗ればいいですね。
そう、以上で、もう、あしこちゃん、そのキラリー、ありがとうございます。